[Music]
hi I'm Stephanie and today I'll show you
how Google clouds visual inspection
products can help you improve the
efficiency of the manufacturing visual
quality control processes in the world
of manufacturing current market
volatility leads to huge operational
pressures you're first in line to
respond quickly to decrease demand
disruption in the supply chain and
interrupted retail channels business
continuity becomes P zero and the weight
of reducing costs falls on your
shoulders
naturally leveraging AI to improve work
efficiency becomes the light at the end
of the tunnel as you start to explore
more ways to advance automation control
manufacturing processes remotely and
enable a remote workforce in the last
several years
visual inspection technologies have been
helping manufacturers ease these
operational pressures image recognition
is being used for electronic part
classification retail Quality Assurance
and even food inspection yet it can be
difficult and costly to implement these
technologies traditional inspection
machinery can cost millions of dollars
per device setting up and deploying AI
for inspection not only needs a reliable
IT infrastructure and expert resources
but there's usually a limited amount of
sample data to start with on top of that
training ml models can be extremely
challenging time-consuming and can
require a specialized skill set that not
all companies have access to take these
defective parts for instance factory
workers are often tasked with finding
these discreet defects on the production
line these small marks can be extremely
subtle making it hard for even a human
eye to be able to see it's no surprise
that this process can be time consuming
and inefficient this is why Google cloud
has a rich offering for visual
inspection products which reduces the
pressure on ground workers and AI
developers and increases time to value
it optimizes for several steps of the
visual inspection process from data
ingestion to production model
optimization google clouds visual
inspection products do this by enabling
customers to efficiently pre process
minimal images for model training then
it bends the data and trains
automatically so you can quickly deploy
the model locally and run inferencing at
the production line better yet you can
continuously improve the model by using
fresh data collected from production
lines to retrain the model in the cloud
giving you increased accuracy as you
discover new use cases here's what an
end-to-end architecture would look like
once a camera is set up on the
production line users can collect images
and store them on the factory floor
server from here the images are uploaded
to Google Cloud using the visual
inspection AI products to begin model
training let's say you want to inspect
an assembled product to find defective
components like damaged glass on devices
labeling thousands of devices is
probably the last thing you want to do
instead using Google Cloud visual
inspection AI products you can upload
images for a new product component and
the solution can automatically extract
this component after you label a few
images the model will analyze all loaded
images to automatically identify the
subset of the data with defects or
anomalies along the way you'll have a
chance to review current model
performance for defect detection using
built in metrics like average precision
precision and recall after downloading
and deploying the trained model
inferencing can be efficiently done
locally on your factory floor for rapid
edge performance and when an unlabeled
image comes in the deployed model can
predict new defects automatically
results can then be viewed in the
central cloud dashboard giving
prediction details and a place to
correct inspections using Google clouds
inspection products you can train
customized ml models in the cloud with
minimum amount of label images leverage
scalable cloud infrastructure for
distributed training and optimized costs
enable production workloads within weeks
versus months efficiently deploy models
and run inferencing at production lines
on-premise for low latency and it's not
just useful for automating the detection
of defective devices Google Cloud visual
inspection products can support a wide
range of discrete manufacturing use
cases such as cosmetic defect detection
and edge detection for electronics
surface quality control for automotives
optical wafer a defect detection for
semiconductors and fabric or packaging
quality control for consumer packaged
goods using Google Cloud visual
inspection products you can increase the
throughput and efficiency of your ml
models
improve overall operations and augment
your workers ability to guarantee the
highest quality products land in the
hands of your customer reach out to your
google cloud rep to learn how you can
deploy visual inspection solutions using
cloud AI products and visit the google
cloud vision AI page to learn more about
our products
[Music]